c'est très simple donc on va commencer
avec en prenant donc 2e elles ont le
pouvoir de remonter le temps ces
madeleines au miel de sologne sont
préparés dans les cuisines de plus de
trois siècles le but en fait est de
faire revivre ses cuisines que ça sente
la pâtisserie et d'essayer que les gens
se projette en fait dans cette dans
cette cuisine du xviie siècle qui est
encore en fonctionnement la petite
astuce pour avoir des jolie madeleine
avec des jeux et chapeau c'est de créer
un choc thermique donc plus votre pâte
va être froide
plus votre four va être chaud et plus
vos madeleine auront des chapeaux après
seulement cinq minutes de cuisson
vient le moment tant attendu de la
dégustation
supervalu et fondante
je sentis le miel j'en aurais peut-être
mis un petit peu plus mais elles sont
bonnes l'occasion aussi pour les
visiteurs de se replonger dans
l'histoire du château votre foi vous
aviez pour vous donner une petite et
dans une cuisine comme ça une vingtaine
de personnes qui travaillaient à temps
plein vous aviez du feu dans la cheminée
24 heures sur 24 ne s'éteignait jamais
on cuisinait en permanence on imagine
bien tout c'est mon tout ce monde se
bousculer
préparer la viande le poisson le pain
l'atelier est organisé tous les après
midi des vacances au château de la
ferté-saint-aubin